if it uh if a pua or or uh anybody in
the manosphere
makes note of the fact that men are
abandoning the churches in record
numbers
uh they i think a lot of guys kind of
get a little a little butt hurt about
that because it took a pua to point that
out to them
and talk about that because that's one
of the points i wanted to bring up with
you was why men are abandoning religion
is it is it is it because it's it's
letting them down is it because they
find the red pill and it's a conflict
with religion is it because
um well primarily i think just from a
societal sense like especially in
western cultures we become less
religious overall so so you have to take
into account that there's a generational
shift right now millennials at least the
last half of the millennial generation
and certainly generation z unless you
were brought up in the church you're
probably not looking to you know find a
faith per se
and uh you're seeing that's that's
problem number one is i think it's a
generational thing like uh people still
want to be religious but they're like
i'm spiritual but not religious right
they they're they're
like ryan would say they're they're
sheep looking for shepherd kind of thing
they they like the idea of the
metaphysical and the supernatural and
let's go take ayahuasca and trip out in
the amazon rainforest or some like
that but um then you know like we were
talking about on we talked about this on
rule zero on saturday is is there's this
eventually these guys you know come to
religion in some way shape or form
and then so that there's that aspect but
i think that the reason why people like
guys who were part of church have left
church is because it has become
overwhelmingly feminized and that is a
primary theme in the book is the uh the
feminization how how bad has it become
feminized because i because i find it
takes you know for the uninitiated for
the plugged in quite a lot to walk away
from
women feminism a religion
like is it really that bad it's tough
it's tough i i think it depends on on
whether or not you were like sort of
born and raised into that religion
uh i think primarily guys when guys
leave the church it's probably because
they got divorced and their wife was the
one that brought them to church and
they're like screw it i'm out i don't
have a base of support well they see
that during that divorce the pastor's on
her side the girls are on her side the
bible studies on her side the the
congregation the synagogue the whatever
is is there's that
female social network that is part of
sort of a religious mindset that's
already pre-established for her in that
church and when there's that separation
there's nothing for that guy now that's
not to say that there aren't churches
that are trying to uh to stimulate i
guess you know influx of guys to come
into the church but unless there's like
some sort of tangible benefit to them
it's really difficult to get single men
who are unchurched into church unless
they have like a real purpose to it
because and i've made this point in the
book is uh the
modern evangelical churches the modern
uh really most like commercial churches
or commercial religion because i can't
just pick on christianity here because
this is a across the board here
is there's nothing for them in church
anymore and and that would that would be
bad enough but once they get into the
church or if they are curious about it
they're like spiritually seeking
something once they get there they find
that the church is really kind of
hostile to them so unless if they're
especially if they're red pill it it
doesn't make sense like they're just
like why would i bother with this
because there's not really anything for
me that i can't get from a religious
text or like doing it on my own or
watching it on tv or whatever else i ask
is because because guys are a glutton
for punishment today especially the
plugged in betas right so they're so it
must be like pretty bad for them to say
you know what this isn't a good use of
my time anymore i'm not going to go here
i think there was a for a while and i
don't know that this is necessarily uh
true uh of the last eight maybe three or
four years but primarily when i was
talking with dal rock and back in like
the late 2000s and you know up to about
2016 2017
um there was a
an idea that you found a quality woman
in church right that was where you go
like
the reason why you you guys are red pill
and the reason why you think of
hypergamy and all the reason why you
guys are jaded and misogynistic is
because you're going for the wrong kind
of girl right you won't find the right
girl at the clubs you won't find the
right girl at the beach you won't find
the right girl in school you have to go
to church in the bible studies and then
you'll find a good girl that's there
well statistically speaking
the church is just as suspect or as just
as um you know
likely to have women who are like you
know single mothers there's single mommy
ministries all over the place there are
conventions for uh uh they call them
what is it uh they're women's ministries
but the women's ministries are for
single mommies specifically for single
mothers and so you've got guys in the
church you've got women in the church
and the women are there primarily
because either they were
raised in that
into into the church to be religious uh
and
whether or not they're sort of still in
the in uh you know the sexual
marketplace it is irrelevant at that
point uh but
the the the problem that you're gonna
see i think is that most of the church
attracts women who are primarily in
their epiphany phase you'll see them
right around 28 29 30 years old and a
lot of them are finding themselves or
they've come to their the end of their
journey of self-discovery and they want
to get right with god and they want to
find a guy who's going to do things the
right way now and where do they find a
good guy at church well the problem is
now in 2021 over the last four or five
years men have abandoned the church so
the good guys that they think are going
to be there are either guys who were
raised in that church and they're still
there and they're single and they're
primarily you know beta males guys that
they don't really want they're not
attracted to and they're not aroused by
or they've got to find a guy outside the
church and then drag him into the church
so so these single mommy congregations
they're they're comprised mostly of
these single moms it's run by a church
well they're like extracurricular things
it's kind of like a dating like matching
sort of system where they're trying to
get these singles moms like wiped out by
some guys and really who are they going
to pull in i mean they're going to pull
in some plugged in beta males right yeah
the the problem i see right now with uh
like singles ministries is what they
what what they're really called and
again
like you have to be single to be part of
the congregation yeah it's and usually
it's like uh college age or older maybe
depends you know there might be a
divorce ministry or whatever else too
but it's uh it's primarily there to set
up believers with other believers at
that point and the unfortunate part of
this of course is that most of those
women are uh
they're there because they're kind of
they they don't want to be judged they
want to be forgiven and the the premise
of forgiveness or the premise of getting
right with god is very appealing when
you are sort of trying to find your way
after your crazy college years you know
back in the back in your you know 18 to
28 years
you